[Música]
la ong human rights watch alerta que la
policía colombiana ha lanzado
proyectiles desde tanquetas durante las
protestas antigubernamentales y contra
la represión policial que dejan hasta
ahora 1700 28 denuncias según reportan
ong locales el presidente cuando que se
mostró ayer abierto a dialogar con todos
los sectores
en río de janeiro al menos 25 personas
perdieron la vida en medio de una redada
de las autoridades contra supuestos
narcotraficantes en una favela naciones
unidas- aseguró que se trató de una
operación desproporcionada con uso
excesivo de la fuerza y pidió una
investigación independiente
avanza el conteo de votos tras las
elecciones regionales en reinounido el
partido conservador del primer ministro
ganó una nueva silla en un bastión
tradicionalmente laborista pero la
atención se centra en los resultados
escoceses decisivos para saber si se
realiza un nuevo referéndum de
independencia
buen día para todos bienvenidos a esta
emisión de noticias en france 24 soy
valentina torre sánchez iniciamos este
informativo en colombia donde
organizaciones internacionales continúan
denunciando abusos de parte de la
policía durante las manifestaciones la
ong human rights watch aseguró que
durante las protestas que ya cumplen
nueve días la policía ha lanzado
proyectiles múltiples desde tanquetas
contra ciudadanos y dice que se trata de
un arma peligrosa e indiscriminada los
señalamientos se producen al tiempo que
oyen engel locales dan cuenta de 1.728
denuncias de abuso policial y al menos
37 fallecidos pese a que durante el día
las manifestaciones se producen de
manera pacífica una vez cae la noche se
registran fuertes enfrentamientos entre
la policía y grupos de ciudadanos anoche
en varias ciudades hubo velatones por
las víctimas de los últimos días uno de
los casos más emblemáticos es el de
lucas biglia un joven que recibió ocho
impactos de bala y su estado es crítico
tras haber participado pacíficamente en
las movilizaciones la presión crece
sobre el presidente de guandú que que
antes
reclamos incesantes de numerosos
sectores se ha mostrado abierto a
dialogar con los líderes del paro
seguimos en colombia y vamos ahora a
cali en el sur occidente del país allí
están nuestros enviados especiales luís
muñoz y juan carlos zapata lluís lo
saludo como amanece cali y que se sabe
de la confusa situación de un camión con
policías vestidos de civil que se
bajaron y empezaron a disparar como lo
había reportado la comunidad
anteriormente
buenos dias valentina desde cali como
todas las mañanas reina la incertidumbre
y es que por ejemplo esta noche en el
sant han escrito desde la minga para
decirnos que en puerto resistencia donde
ha estado este equipo se produjeron
disparos en la noche de ayer así que
como todas las mañanas esclarecer los
hechos está resultando difícil lo que sí
que se ha podido esclarecer es que ayer
durante el día nuestro equipo estaba
grabando y escuchamos disparos luego
pudimos saber que fue un camión del que
bajaron aparentes civiles que dispararon
contra manifestantes después los
manifestantes se dirigieron hacia el
camión y encontraron prendas polis
policiales la policía ha reconocido que
ellos participaron en ese operativo y
que el operativo era para levantar los
retenes que se estaban produciendo en la
ciudad y que los manifestantes les
habían atacado hiriendo a dos policías
sin embargo desde los manifestantes
dicen que los policías los que
recibieron las balas fueron por el
ejército una unidad del ejército que
estaba allá y que custodió a los propios
manifestantes así que una situación un
poco confusa
cabe destacar que respecto a estos
bloqueos nuestro equipo también ayer don
decidió ir a una plaza de mercado para
conocer cómo son los ánimos de la
población y realmente
nos mostró más el dedo de culpa hacia el
gobierno que no hacia los manifestantes
veamos el informe
cielito 10 ven de boca chicos en la
plaza de mercado de santa elena en cali
unos jóvenes del lugar le preguntan que
por qué tiene precios tan altos que
vende caro hacia el que ha tenido que
recurrir a un corredor humanitario han
llegado alimentos pero los compradores
denuncian que los precios están
triplicando algunos vecinos antes de la
subida de precios aseguran que ya les
costaba comer nos estamos muriendo de
hambre habemos muchas familias que
solamente comemos un desayuno o un
almuerzo las colas de gasolineras son
kilométricas y en algunos casos se está
tomando la gasolina vecinos aseguran que
sí que hay combustible pero que no la
quieren vender la gasolina no es que de
las en robando acá la gasolina no no la
quisieron seguir vendiendo los pozos que
estaban saqueando esto es porque
nosotros necesitamos movilizarnos ante
esta situación vendedores piden que por
fin se llegue a una solución estamos mal
en el país no hay alimentos no hay
absolutamente nada lo que necesitamos es
que el gobierno trate de conciliar con
nosotros los colombianos y que todos se
normalicen en colombia otros vecinos
aseguran que entienden la protesta de
los jóvenes
la juventud es como usted en su casa
venga dijo usted que lo represado hasta
el crece el cristiano iba a pensar esto
es lo que pasará con esta juventud ya
crecieron un argumento recurrente en el
mercado donde la gente señala su dedo
más allá de los bloqueos llegando hasta
el propio gobierno en río de janeiro en
brasil la policía realizó una redada en
una de las favelas de la ciudad que
acabó con 25 muertos tras un tiroteo
entre las fuerzas de seguridad y
supuestos narcotraficantes con esa cifra
de fallecidos la operación se convirtió
en la mayor matanza en río en los
últimos 16 años activistas por los
derechos de la población afro y vecinos
de la favela denunciaron abusos
policiales
rodrigo sedano nos amplía la información
nueva redada policial en una favela de
río de janeiro que con 25 muertos se
convirtió en la mayor matanza en la
capital carioca en 16 años se trata de
la primera acción de este tipo desde que
el año pasado la corte suprema de
justicia suspendiera a las operaciones
policiales tras la muerte de al menos 65
personas durante el confinamiento el
resultado de esto es el fortalecimiento
del tráfico de drogas sin presencia
policial el tráfico de drogas en gana
poder
expande sus dominios y avanza cada vez
más en la sociedad la redada del jueves
buscaba desmontar un grupo de
narcotraficantes que actuaba en la
favela y reclutaba a menores según las
autoridades pero finalmente acabó en un
tiroteo con la policía algunos vecinos
denunciaron ejecuciones por parte de los
uniformados algo que se negó desde la
institución policial
la única ejecución fue la de un oficial
de policía tristemente asesinado con
frialdad por los narcotraficantes fue
rafael reuters mucho las otras muertes
ocurrieron lamentablemente mientras los
narcotraficantes apuntaban a la policía
y luego fueron neutralizados
es así de simple esta mujer relata sin
embargo como la policía entró en su casa
y mató a uno de los supuestos
delincuentes sin mediar palabra aunque
uno dieron tiempo el joven de decir nada
mi única reacción fue proteger a mi
familia mi niña de nueve años vio todo
nunca más volverá a querer dormir en esa
habitación a mamá quiere dormir en ese
cuarto human rigths watch pidió una
investigación exhaustiva independiente
sobre las muertes según el organismo la
policía de río mató a 543 personas en lo
que va de año mientras que al menos
cuatro policías habrían fallecido en
acciones similares a la del jueves
continuamos en nicaragua luego de que el
legislativo nombrará nuevos magistrados
en el consejo supremo electoral la unión
europea rechazó esta y otras medidas que
facilitan extender por cinco años el
gobierno de daniel ortega según la
oficina del portavoz del bloque europeo
las medidas que establecen restricciones
al proceso electoral que culminará en
noviembre no cumplen con las
recomendaciones de una misión de
observación electoral que hizo la unión
en 2011 y tampoco acatan las
de la organización de estados américanos
este jueves el nuevo consejo supremo
electoral de nicaragua convocó las
elecciones para el próximo 7 de
noviembre
ese día se elegirá presidente
vicepresidente diputados de la asamblea
y diputados del parlamento
centroamericano
avanza el conteo de los votos en las
elecciones regionales de reino unido no
obstante los resultados finales sólo se
conocerán hasta el fin de semana por los
retrasos causados por medidas para
controlar el coi 19 el partido del
primer ministro boris johnson se hizo
con una nueva silla en el parlamento por
la ciudad dejar el culo un bastión
tradicionalmente laborista sin embargo
los ojos están puestos sobre los
resultados al parlamento escocés que son
determinantes para el futuro del reino
unido debido a la promesa del gobernante
partido nacional escocés que si cuenta
con el respaldo suficiente realizará un
nuevo referendo sobre la independencia
de escocia
espero que el bote en escocia cuente
esta vez
sabes y si el país quiere ir adelante y
ser independiente es una buena decisión
es el momento correcto para eso seguro
yo sé que hay mucha gente que quiere la
independencia y tienen sus propias
razones para eso hacer un día sin espada
sin embargo yo digo que estoy contenta
quedándonos donde estamos en este
momento esto está bien para mí james
bain y a ustedes gracias por su sintonía
los invitamos a ampliar todas las
noticias en nuestra web france24
puntocom
[Música]